in 1865 Mendel often considered the
father of modern genetics comes up with
a structured way of thinking about these
inheritable factors which we now call
genes and then as we go into the early
1900's his work was rediscovered and
people start to say ok we have we see
how some of these traits get passed on
in these somewhat predictable ways we
can put some structure around it but
what is the actual biological mechanism
for that what how how are these traits
encoded at a cellular or at a molecular
level and so in 1902 and we talked about
this in a previous video Bovary and
Sutton come up with the chromosome
theory based on seeing how chromosomes
separate and pair during cell division
and saying hey those seem to be seemed
to map up quite well to what Mendel
described by these heritable factors
then we start having a lot more evidence
for this Morgan is able to show that
these mutant that a mutant I color trait
seems to seems to be passed on in a way
that shows that it is on the xx
chromosome and his him and his team
start doing a lot more work especially
with fruit flies to show that hey
chromosomes are the basis for where
these heritable factors are but then we
even within the chromosomes people
weren't sure chromosomes were made up of
proteins made up of DNA what was the
molecule or the set of molecules that
actually encoded for this for these
heritable traits and at first most of
the weight was on the chromosome was on
the protein side because proteins were
these complex molecules that had all of
this variety that seemed like it could
could code for for these heritable
traits while DNA at least early on
seemed like a kind of boring molecule
people people assumed people assumed
that there wasn't a lot of diversity in
DNA they assumed that even if you go
from one species to another that the DNA
molecule was fundamentally the same so
early on people actually were on the
side more of the proteins but then more
and more evidence came the way of came
on DNA side you had Griffiths experiment
where he was able to show hey I could
take this this heat-killed bacteria but
if I mix it with some other living
bacteria that somehow there's some
transformation principle that transforms
the the living bacteria into the into
the type of species that I had in the
heat killed and you go to 1944 and Avery
McCarty and MacLeod are able to show
some pretty good evidence that that the
actual principle that the the thing that
was left and that heat killed bacteria
was probably DNA was probably DNA and
then we get even more conclusive
evidence with the experiments of Hershey
and chase and we have a whole video on
this where they say hey what is what is
it that viruses inject into bacteria to
hijack their their their genetic system
and they say hey it's not proteins it is
DNA that does this so they provide much
more conclusive evidence on the side of
DNA but even at that point we as a
community as a civilization still didn't
know what the actual structure of DNA
was and we also did not know how did
that structure actually code for all of
these heritable factors and the work
culminates with Watson and Crick but it
was dependent on all of the people I
mentioned and more and one person who
should get special credit for one
getting a little bit more evidence on
the side of DNA and helping Watson Crick
actually there's several people but in
particular chargaff and rosalind
Franklin who don't probably Andros on
Franklin particular probably does not
get as much credit as she deserves
chargaff's the one that showed that hey
DNA actually is more interesting than
people appreciated he noticed that the
frequencies the frequencies of the
nitrogenous bases of adenine guanine
cytosine and thymine in DNA varies
across species varies across across
species and something that somehow
coding for what makes a species of
species well it would have to vary
across BC so that makes DNA interesting
and then the other thing that he noticed
this was key for Watson and Crick's work
is that the frequency of guanine is
equal to the frequency of cytosine in
DNA and the frequency of adenine is
equal to the frequency of thymine in DNA
and so it's a clue that these somehow
are associated with each other they
somehow pair with each other and so we
get to the early 50s
we had all this evidence that DNA is the
molecular basis you have chargaff with
his rules called chargaff's rules and
then you have rosalind Franklin and
she's doing she's doing she's imaging
x-ray
she's imaging diffraction patterns from
x-rays beamed into crystals of DNA so
what I mean by crystal of DNA a crystal
is taking a bunch of molecules in a ring
and arranging them in a regular pattern
so a crystal of DNA a DNA molecule
that's one DNA molecule then you have
another DNA molecule and then you have
another DNA molecule and then you beam
x-rays atom an x-ray is our key because
their wavelength the wavelength of an
x-ray is small enough is to capture the
features at an atomic level so you beam
x-rays and then the x-rays diffract and
then you capture the pattern of that
diffraction and depending on the
structures in the actual molecules
you'll have different diffraction
patterns and Franklin's famous
diffraction pattern is shown right over
here and when she immediately saw this
it had some of the telltale cues for a
helical structure now I wouldn't read
too much into this if you're not an
expert reader of x-ray diffraction
patterns this does not is this in a
direct image of a of a DNA molecule but
they knew they she already knew in fact
people in this community already knew
that this X pattern was a telltale sign
was a telltale sign for for a helical
structure of some kind and then they are
also able to look at the different the
other clues here to think about what's
the spacing different between different
molecules and even the spacing between
the different turns of the helix
structure now once again this
diffraction pattern it's not a direct
image and it's it takes a lot of it's a
very well-developed expertise to
backwards map how things will diffract
into the thing that actually caused the
diffraction and they would take it from
multiple different angles to get a
better understanding of it and actually
today you have computers doing this that
could take a diffraction pattern and
start to construct what the you know the
electron clouds of what the actual
molecule looks like so frankly this was
painstaking work
and she already had a sense that it was
probably she knew it was a helical
structure but she was waiting to get a
little bit more evidence before she
published her work now at the same time
you have Watson and Crick here who were
trying to solve the structure and they
got a hold of Franklin's work with the
help of Maurice Wilkins here who
Franklin worked with and they were able
to establish that it wasn't a single
helix but it was a double helix and you
actually had these base pairs forming
the rungs of the double helix and that
was really interesting because that
showed how DNA could replicate itself
how it could contain actual information
and we go into much much more depth into
future videos now the sad part about
this story is Wilkins Watson and Crick
went on to win a Nobel Prize
Franklin unfortunately she died very
young and you're not allowed to receive
a Nobel Prize if you've if you've passed
away so she's very deserving of it this
work which is a lot of people consider
to be one of the biggest discoveries in
human in science was based on what she
did arguably had Watson Crick not had
access to her work they would not have
been able to figure it out and if she
just stuck to what she was doing without
other people having Hex's work she might
have been able to get to that same
conclusion so she is one of the people
who sometimes the history of science
overlooks but this isn't all you know
this isn't to not give credit to Watson
Crick either there was still a lot of
very powerful intuitive leaps that they
had to make to come up with this double
helix structure this anti parallel
double helix structure where they go in
opposite directions but they bridge with
with these nitrogenous bases pairing
with each other and this is a big big
big big deal throughout most of human
history we knew that traits were passed
on but traits seemed like this magical
mystical thing how do i encode my you
know I know my laughs is like my dad's
but how is that actually encoded in in
my DNA and now we're able to see that a
lot of what we consider about ourselves
to be us is encoded in these molecules
and encoded in these base pairs so it's
beautiful it's incredible it's it's it's
shedding light on one of the biggest
mysteries of what makes humans actually
all life life
you